now to lose a loved one is devastating
to lose a loved one to murder it's
horrific
a situation that Marie McCourt's knows
all too well her daughter Helen was
murdered three decades ago by a man
named Ian Simms who refuses to reveal
the whereabouts of her body lobbying for
change Marie has created a petition
calling for murderers to be denied
parole until they disclose the
whereabouts of their victims remains
Marie's with us now
hiya we chatted a while ago yes we did I
thought we got since then we've got a
lot further because the bill was read
out by my MP con him again today in the
Commons and it was it's just amazing you
know to listen to him reading us house I
couldn't believe all these years I've
been wanting this done and there was
actually happening in front of me and it
was it was very well accepted by the MPs
that were all there and in fact there
were it was all yeas and we never had
any knows or wherever it's just this day
and and then the speaker mr. bekku asked
honor to present his bill to the the
officers who were on the desk in front
of him so he had to come down the steps
go to the center and then just Martley
walked down and passed the bill over
ball that will be studied now and on the
3rd of February 2017 if it's passed it
will then go through as a law talk to me
if you can and if you want to about what
happened all those years ago to Helen
and and the fact that you still don't
know where she is
yes Helen Helen was she was always very
punctual we didn't have mobile phones
then she worked in Liverpool at the
royal insurance so she had to catch two
trains and then a bus to the village
where we live on the outskirts of
Merseyside
and if she missed her train she would
ring me from the station from a coal box
and say Oh mom I'm going to be 15-20
minutes late but that's strange to him
so she arrived home after filming me
three times so you will have me tea
ready won't you mom because I'm going
out today two o'clock with a boyfriend
and I said I know I have a bad memory
love breast not that funny and she she
didn't arrive home burrowed head on the
stick on the back what - sex news on the
local radio that the trains from
Merseyside from Lime Street to Wigan had
been delayed because the tree had blown
onto the line so I didn't worry though
oh that's why she's not wrong and I had
to tell you already
and then it got to 7 then 8th - coming
up to 8 o'clock and I thought this can't
be right so i rung the the station
eventually got through and they said it
wouldn't have affected you daughter's
dream because it was only after - hair
stopped up the trains they had to tend
at st. Alan's where she got off because
of the tree and so then we went into
Liverpool tried to trace their steps
report it to the police in Liverpool and
then I run them when we go home i
wronged them every hour on the hour as
the officer told me I could and then two
officers come out at about half past
four in the morning
- Kellan's picture away with them yes
that's right yes they actually picked
that off off the coffee table they asked
for that one in specific I didn't know
why then but it would pay that the
officer recognized talents picture
because he often traveled on the same
train into Liverpool as her beautiful
girl mmm beautiful girl this man who is
responsible for her death Sims he has
never said where her body is no no now
he's never admitted to the crime he says
he's innocent
and spice of all the evidence against
him and that evidence has increased from
when he was tried and found guilty
unanimously by a jewelry it was one
hundred and sixty eight thousand times
more likely that he was the killer of my
daughter what would you say to him if
you could talk to him this afternoon
Marie and say you know I just I just
need closure on this I
he's up for parole next year I think no
2018 okay yeah mm-hmm I would just I
wrote a letter to him you know yes I
wrote it when his first appeal was
thrown out in 92 91 92 and I never pour
anything Calgary in the letter I just
appealed to him and I said you know
please just tell me where where her body
can be recovered and you won't hear from
me again I'll leave you to get on with
your sentence and I'm the reply I
received back was it's obsessing it was
horrible yeah and yeah it was no it
really was yeah adversity he like kept
about how he was in prison and he had
two beautiful children and and but then
he seemed to lose that the luster is
full of threats and I've always had that
letter captain his person file to be
read by any person at the parole board
and I was convinced that they could not
release them because it was a
threatening letter threatening to me to
my family and accusations and we didn't
even know the man you know what
difference would it make to you in the
family if you finally knew where she was
it would be it would be a great relief
for me you know I need to bind I think
of my friend when he Johnson defendants
mom and I know what when he went through
and when she was very very ill
she she just wanted to thank you and she
didn't get her wish
Ian Brady wouldn't do that and I I'm gay
I'm 73 now I know I just think why I
just think you know it could be my turn
next I don't want to die until I know
where Holland remains all I need to know
about my body can go in with hers or
what remains are found of her and I just
I would back this man please just tell
me where her body else just let the
police recover us and you will never
hear from me again they could release
him within one side have the funeral you
know any time after that they could
release some it wouldn't affect me
because I've got my daughter back and I
think that that's the problem with these
kind of killers you know we have over 38
families we know of 30 families quite a
few of them came to the Commons today to
be there to hear this bill read because
they're in the same situation as me and
this is all because DNA can say who the
killer is even though they haven't got a
body these days and and they were there
supporting this bill and and we need
this law to be made because we can't
have families going through the torment
and pain I've had to stop her for almost
three decades and this law would mean
that people would not get parole until
they admitted weather is to my mind a
judge when they're found guilty of
murder a judge when he sentences them he
has to pass a life sentence for murder
and that's what the judge did he said
you've been found guilty of the murder
of Helen McCourt
after that I can only give you a life
sentence but then a delayed two days
they go on and give a minimum sentence
and I say that shouldn't happen when
there is nobody it should be it's a life
sentence and until you cooperate and
allow the remains your victim to be
recovered or the body of your victim to
be
recovered then you will you will never
come out to prison life will mean when
he's the only person that can ease that
pain for us yes for all our families you
know I've left those families going home
tonight they were there today
they said it helped them enormous ly to
know that someone was fighting for our
loved ones rights you know they were
human beings and they they have their
lives taken from them and it's their
families who so far if we the human
rights Bell will not let you punish a
prisoner by far we have a tough tripping
on our head every minute of every day
every time we see a body has been found
in an area that could be we think I
think is it it's a talent could it be
Helen and and it upsets me when it isn't
because then I think Oh some other
family are going to get terrible news
today and they may have thought they
loved one had just gone missing and not
been in touch with them and they're
going to find out they've been murdered
and missing all this time and and I
think that the government has to make
this law because otherwise they are
party to patan ors
the innocent victims through torture
through hell and they have to justify
that and i think the only way they can
do it is by saying until you tell us
where your victim's remains can be
recovered then you will only then can
you look forward to being released all
our families that wither today or say
exactly the same as me they don't care
what happens to the killer all if they
want to say loved one back and they will
lead them if they get released that's
fine
you know do we accept that they've there
they're in prison but we can't allow
prison that we can't tell our killers to
control and that's what they are their
controllers because they won't release
their victim to anyone it's a secret to
them and no
come back and talk to us again in
February won't you when it hopefully is
because yes okay it's great to Ashley
thanks very much for coming